hey guys it's Justine and we were back
with another iPhone se video today I
wanted to do a photo challenge I wanted
to test out the camera on this but I
didn't want to do it in a traditional
way because well I can't I can't go
outside I can't really go anywhere other
than in my house and my backyard
so I asked you guys on Twitter to give
me some things to photograph so it's
kind of like a little quarantine photo
challenge to make this even more fun I
wanted to test out some of the moment
lenses if you guys have never seen these
before basically a bunch of different
lenses that you can attach to your
iPhone to get all of the different
camera effects like wide-angle there's
an anamorphic that's a telephoto and
they just attach to a case so this is
the moment case this one was actually
made for the iPhone 7 and iPhone 8 they
do have a new iPhone se one coming out
but basically it's probably gonna be the
same exact thing the rear camera is 12
megapixels and the front-facing is 7 of
course this does have only one
wide-angle lens which is where these
moment lenses will come into play so
let's pop on this case and go take some
photos hey Jen time for a photo
challenge so I got a bunch of tweets on
Twitter the first one it was a
suggestion of toilet paper so I thought
maybe we can put the toilet paper on
Daddy's head we'll put it on his head
and my head he's like no I just want to
let you know I don't support weights
weights you ever got ready 1 2 3
don't write a paper go
yay total paper head okay now I'll put
on my head one two three okay we got it
get the got a bun you're such a good boy
thank you
thank you oh that mouth stinks I think
I'm just the home but I actually kind of
miss it - it's so nice because now that
we're wearing facemasks all the time
outside take a picture of my amiibo
collection this isn't my entire
collection but I don't want to get them
all out so I'm gonna take a picture with
a regular first and I'm gonna pop this
ultra wide on to get an ultra wide
amiibo shot whoa this looks cool let's
do a video just because gosh I feel like
we should be shooting a music video
right now Wario this is not your best
angle alright what do we have next a
chocolate chip cookie close up or any
food for that matter I don't have any
cookies I do have a cookie I have a
hidden cookie somewhere I've had this
cookie sitting in my desk upstairs in my
office since my birthday I can't believe
I have an email do you think it's still
good we're gonna do macro for this one
so this has this little plastic on it so
that you're able to get super close up
oh yeah oh my goodness
I can see a raisin
[Music]
this is so close I want to show you what
this looks like
without the macro lens so I'm using a
normal camera now and this is as close
as I can get without things getting
blurry
so we're going from this to this with
the macro lens unfortunately I think the
cookie has expired though oh here's one
Nintendo switch while playing Animal
Crossing oh ho oh geez okay I wonder
where we can find that Oh Jenna hello
are you playing Animal Crossing yes well
I'm gonna take a portrait photo of you
here playing Animal Crossing a smile
um I think I kind of might like a casual
photo of you like oh yes candid oh yeah
you look good look like you just sold
those turnips for how much ah 606 bells
you look good you look happy here give
me that I got it
just let me let me get comfy on the
hammock for you
I'm trying to make the Nintendo switch
your body okay I don't put your arms up
like we're right there right there don't
move this is creative Oh Oh an artistic
selfie with Maddie Maddie where did you
go there you are
we have to get an artistic selfie for
the people I wonder if they want me in
it or they want just mad
[Music]
these don't look very artistic but we
can go in and edit dramatic cool do you
like that one it makes you look good so
it says you can't do pet portraits but
I'm gonna try it anyway no person
detected ok well he is a person and I
don't understand why next photo
challenge is all of your Apple watch
bands
ok artistic I need one while you're down
here hi Maddy what's this what's that
[Music]
this just looks like a mess
artistic balance what the lens is on
okay we're gonna do a macro whoa that's
really good I know okay we've got some
macro shot okay I said one of your eye
I'm just for the record nobody requested
this
[Music]
it looks cool
Wow Wow I really need to work my mascara
application David wants anything camo
huh
oh I could do that hey mom seriously
this is quarantine fashion items oh and
it's all the way up me I find us we
don't even need a mask
you should come I know okay ready want
not doesn't matter do like a pose like a
stealth pose
one two stop moving it's hot in there
it's okay already portrait okay I need
you like an angle like models like
really you know contort their body so
they look like models
okay look like a model no let's do nice
why I'm gonna get like one down like it
alone would be like you know like do I
look cool um sure ready that's so good
Oh take a couple more I know a new
profile pic all right Jenn so we're
gonna do a tick-tock we can't use the
audio in this video because I'll get a
copyright strike but on tick-tock if
that's the joy we can use copy written
music yes okay is it still doing the
filter yeah where are lies in space good
okay so I want to like kind of like walk
forward and unzip okay we could do
something and they can cut if I walk
this way in the street yes
[Music]
we had a request for cream weekd
banana and campbell soup so first up I
think we're gonna take the cream of
wheat I think this would be a really
cool shot to do some macro of the cream
of wheat but also we need a selfie with
a great week I haven't done any portrait
selfies yet this is perfect
I can't wait so much I love cream we
quarantine classic I don't know dump
this out and waste it it's my prized
possession and just do a little I've
actually never really stopped just
seeing what it looks like is this any
way since we're doing this macarons
let's add a banana for scale I'm so
close to it it's crazy
Campbell's soup chicken and stars I got
this in case I ever get sick like this
is my favorite sick meal Jana suggested
since you can't do portrait mode because
it tries to detect a person because it's
using AI to try to find a person that's
a Starbucks cup might work because it
will see if it's a person hmm Starbucks
actually sent me this there's a little
picture of Maddie on it it's not
speaking of the person I won't know
however Hey look here for me it says
move closer it detected a junior person
I haven't written one of these in like
five years five years trying to get my
footing back I don't understand why it
doesn't think this is a person person
not a person you know why cuz it's smart
have you guys enjoyed this video I had
so much fun making this of course your
suggestions were incredible also thank
you Jenna she's not there anymore but
she took some great photos what I really
loved about this is the fact that yes
this camera is great but if you do want
to add other lenses you can still get
some really incredible effects don't
forget to subscribe because I have some
more iPhone se videos coming up for you
if there's anything else you would like
to see me test out with this leave them
in the comments below also any questions
anything that you might want to know you
know what to do ask the questions and I
might answer I'm sweating in this onesie
but are you in the onesie sweating I'm
in I'm sweating in the ones again I'm in
the onesie sweater did you steal my
brush I have been theft 'add I did not
this is my purse is over there Oh
custard night your mom's a thief I'm a
thief in the night
I'm stealing brushes